And said this one in this study, this study here from PubMed, lists five phytochemicals that target cancer stem cells.
I understand that cancer stem cells survive chemo and radiation, and are largely responsible for cancer reoccurrence, and we could add cancer metastasis.
Apparently no FDA approved drugs kill cancer stem cells, these are the same thing as circulated to their cells.
And it seems that these phytochemicals are the best way of dealing with cancer stem cells.
They're curcumin, EGCG, which is the cancun from green tea extract.
So for a fade resmeratrol and jettestep, shouldn't I be taking all of these at least, since there are more, like pectosol C and such, what are high quality products in your store that fulfill this?
Does cancer stem cells are circulated to their cells render concerned for high blood levels of other circulated to their cells mute?
Why does standard oncology not seem to be concerned with cancer stem cells?
Well, it's the first question, or the last question first, standard oncology does not seem to be concerned with circulated to their cells or cancer stem cells because they don't have a protocol for it.
That's the only thing I can think of, they just don't.
They don't try to prevent metastasis store prevent disease, every matter of fact you go in and you talk to your oncologist and I think everybody probably had a similar experience where they said diet was no not important supplements were not important lifestyle is not important just let me take care of this cancer with.
Surgery, chemo, radiation or immunotherapy and that's they just treat disease that way so they just follow the protocol in their on their computer manual.
So yes, could a person be taking all of these? Yes, is there anything wrong with that? First of all, I would say the genestine one is from mainly from a study of ovarian cancer.
I don't think genestine has as much significance for circulating tumor cells as for much other than the ovarian, but that's another point of discussion.
But there, but there are a lot these are these are mainly except for so far, but EGC, curcumin, respiratory, quercetin, these are anti-inflammatories so they don't necessarily destroy circulating tumor cells, but they help your body with any inflammatory process.
So, you know, the flavonoids in general are good.
Should everybody be taking these? Well, yes and no, the reason why we do the cheek swab test is to test for what would be best for you so that you're not taking way too many things.
Now, are some things like these things bad to take? Are they hard at your liver if you don't, yes, if they're not necessarily doing anything for you?
Yes and no, I've had people take, you know, to high doses of curcumin for a long period of time and develop antibodies because they have such gut issues that they end up developing antibodies to turmeric.
So, I mean, it is possible that you can develop an anti, antibodies to different things and then you, you have a sensitivity to them, so it becomes inflammatory instead of anti inflammatory.
So that is possible. I have this question come up in different forms all the time. I heard this is good. I read this article. Can I take this too?
Yeah, we could, you could. And you, and you may do whatever you feel like you should do whatever you feel like God is leading you to do. God, you feel like God put this article in front of me.
I really feel I should take some of these. Then you certainly have every right to do that. I'm just trying to help you not take too many things.
What do we do? You know, I know there's a lot of, I mean, I have some people come to me and they're literally and, you know, people on over 150 different supplements.
I mean, it just is counterintuitive to me that, you know, you take too many things and you can overwhelm your liver, you can overwhelm your detoxification pathways.
If you absorb these things and your body can't use them, they have to go out of your body somehow and they have to use your detox ordals and that can be overwhelming to your body.
So I don't always think just because there's a study that shows that it's good for, that it could be good for me that everybody should be taking it.
But I also don't think that you can't, if you feel like to do some.